politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisodes 247 ce
soir mon invité et le vice-président de
50 ans en Yvelines délégué au sport et
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
2024 Laurent mazori
l'île de politique
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir merci de m'accueillir
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes aussi
mère adjoint d'Élancourt délégué à la
culture on va revenir avec vous
longuement ce soir sur le dossier des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines accueillera
certaines épreuves vous êtes en charge
de ces questions pour l'agglomération on
va revenir sur les différentes
polémiques aussi qui accompagnent ces
Jeux Olympiques et la préparation de
l'événement qui est l'événement le plus
regardé de la planète vous avez vu
Laurent omazaury j'imagine le prix des
places le Comité olympique nous avons
donc annoncé nous avait annoncé des jeux
populaires et pourtant le prix déplace a
fait polémique 2700 euros pour assister
à la cérémonie d'ouverture sur la scène
690 euros pour suivre une session
d'athlétisme ou encore 500 euros pour la
natation il y avait des places aussi à
24 euros en tant qu'observateur du
dossier est-ce que vous avez été surpris
de voir ces chiffres et cette polémiques
alors surpris
puisque quand on regarde en fait
l'historique des Jeux Olympiques on
assiste à la même phénomène y compris
dans des pays beaucoup plus on va dire
beaucoup moins commerciaux peut-être que
peuvent être la France ou moins ouvertes
à l'économie de marché et on sait tous
très bien que les Jeux Olympiques
coûtent à la fois cher et puis qui
incendent d'opérations et de position
sur cette certains sports qui impactent
directement le prix du billet après en
ce qui concerne 50 ans les vignes je ne
veux parler qu'au nom de 50 ans Yvelines
on a la chance d'avoir des épreuves très
accessibles les plus chers sont celles
évidemment du Vélodrome national parce
qu'on a un nombre de places qui est
limité à 5000 places au maximum dans
lequel on va trouver ces fameux billets
à 24 euros et on va trouver des billets
un petit peu plus cher mais on n'ira pas
au-delà des 100 110 euros pour les
meilleurs places et puis surtout on a
une chance extraordinaire le golf fait
partie des
de dire on va dire de manifestation qui
comme ça a priori ont l'impression
d'avoir le plus grand symbole marketing
élitiste alors que les places ils sont
très peu cher on a beaucoup de place à
24 euros le VTT je n'en parle pas sur la
colline Delancourt on aura les places
également les moins chères et puis on a
une chance extraordinaire on a aussi des
épreuves gratuites à qui est le passage
qui sont le passage des épreuves de
cyclisme sur route à la fois féminine et
masculine et puis des prix bien
également BMX ils sont tout à fait
abordables donc oui je constate
effectivement qu'il y a des prix parfois
un peu prohibitifs sur une partie des
installations olympiques mais ce n'est
pas le cas à 50 ans Yvelines donc on a
eu cette chance de pouvoir faire
participer ainsi le plus grand nombre de
tous ceux qui viendront nous visiter
alors d'un côté on souhaite que les jeux
soient raisonnables économiquement que
ça ne coûte pas trop d'argent à l'état
et que ça n'explose pas le budget comme
on a pu voir sur certains pays qui donc
avaient organisé les jeux précédemment
est-ce que certains qui dénoncent ces
prix ne font-ils pas de la démagogie
selon vous on s'est très français on
condamne aujourd'hui ce que l'on a
ensens hier si on n'avait pas été
candidat aux Jeux Olympiques on aurait
dit que les deux matchs qu'on ne le soit
pas si on l'est on regrette de l'être
quand on a une politique spécifique pour
le sport en même temps on va avoir au
moment des Jeux Olympiques une espèce de
grande nettoyage familiale au sein des
instances du sport c'est un sujet dont
on pourrait parler on voit ce qui est
plus passé
au-delà du phare qui est sur la France
et de l'exportation de l'image de la
France à l'étranger pour attirer ensuite
des investisseurs et des touristes dans
le long terme on voit que ça marche
parce que nous on est à Saint-Quentin
l'expérience de la Ryder Cup qui nous a
prouvé que pendant plusieurs années et
cela continue on a des gens qui viennent
spécifiquement au golf national et donc
sur le territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines
donc du coup dépenser des devises pour
participer jouer au golf sur sur un
terrain qui a accueilli un événement
international donc il en sera de même
pour les Jeux olympiques mais au-delà de
tout cela c'est l'héritage que
laisseront les JO c'est la capacité
d'avoir anticipé des travaux qui
auraient pris 30 ans à être réalisés et
de les faire aujourd'hui dans le biais
et dans la continuité de l'événement
olympique et donc c'est avant tout et
au-delà du sport un élément structurant
pour le territoire en termes
d'aménagement de nos territoires vous
avez vu la semaine dernière la démission
de livelinoise Brigitte Enrique du CNOSF
est-ce que ça vocation vous qui suivez
le dossier à déstabiliser l'organisation
ou pas je pense que non parce que les
institutions résistent toujours et
particulièrement en France à ceux qui
les dirigent on cette capacité là aussi
à détruire ce que l'on a en censé un
jour je pars entre les histoires du
CNOSF je sais que la transition entre
l'ancien président et la nouvelle
présidente ont été compliquées je sais
qu'ils se sont renvoyés procédure ce
procédure ça ne me regarde pas en tant
que territoire de 50 ans divine je ne
veux avoir affaire ni de près ni de loin
avec ses éléments là mais ce que je sais
c'est que c'est lui perdurera et que
dans son rôle pour les Jeux Olympiques
je rappelle que ce rôle il est
essentiellement autour de du village des
athlètes enfin pas du village des
athlètes pardon de de France 24 alors le
l'endroit où les athlètes après les jeux
vont rencontrer la population dont les
médias c'est surtout cette partie là qui
qui dépendait du CNOSF ça perdurera ça
aura lieu que ce soit l'ancienne
présidente un nouveau président ou une
nouvelle présidente qui soit là le CNSF
continuera de fonctionner comme la
Fédération Française continuera de
fonctionner et comme l'État lui-même
quand une fonctionnait quand il y a un
changement de présence ou de majorité
alors on parlait des places tout à
l'heure pour assister aux Jeux
Olympiques si on n'a pas de place il y
aura aussi la possibilité
résister aux jeux dans des zones de
célébration qui seront mises donc en
place dans chaque arrondissement de
Paris sauf dans le septième dans toute
l'Île-de-France aussi on en parle la
région il réfléchit je pense pourquoi
pas à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est-ce que
vous avez des éléments sur sur cette
question alors c'est plus que la région
y réfléchit nous avons été moteur de la
mise en place de ce qu'on appelle mais
on n'a pas le droit de le dire parce que
c'est un nom en horrible nos anglo-saxon
les fans qui sont ces dieux de
célébration à la française on dit des
zones de célébrations
peut-être trouver un autre notre façon
de nommer mais la zone de célébration
elle s'installera à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisque nous
en sommes l'initiative elle sera dans
l'île de loisirs elle sera ouverte sur
toute la durée des Jeux olympiques mais
pas sur celle des paralympiques pour des
raisons d'organisation et de timing et
paralympiques étant plus tard on préfère
réserver le paralympisme sur la partie
vraiment audiovisuelle et d'ailleurs je
tiens à dire que les derniers Jeux
Olympiques ont eu un grand succès
d'audience sur le paralympique pour la
première fois sont les Jeux
paralympiques qui ont été les plus
suivis je suis certain que ce Paris le
seront également mais vous devrait donc
dans l'île de loisirs une fan zone qui
sera ouverte toute la journée pendant
toute la durée des Jeux dans lequel il y
aura de nombreux animations sportives
mais pas que sportives également très
ludique avec les partenaires de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je tiens par
avance à remercier les entreprises je
vais pas les lister ici parce qu'il y a
des marchés en cours mais toutes celles
qui s'inscriront dans cette logique là
sont bien entendu les bienvenus et elles
savent de qui je parle et elles ont
vraiment de très belles choses à montrer
pour occuper les gens toute la journée
bien entendu écran géant bien entendu
retranscription de l'ensemble des
épreuves mais pas que celle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de toutes les
épreuves des JO animation musicale
endroit pour également tester et goûter
tout ce que les Yvelines et 50 ans
peuvent produire en termes de
restauration qualitative parce que nous
accueillerons à la fois notre population
nos 5 continents nos yvelinois mais nous
accueillerons également toutes celles et
tous ceux qui viendront nous visiter qui
en quittant les épreuves n'auront qu'une
envie c'est de passer dans ce type de
loisir pour aller sur cette zone de
célébration c'est un très grand enjeu
dont nous sommes à l'origine dont
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est à
l'origine de l'initiative alors
l'organisation a voulu aussi s'inscrire
dans des Jeux Olympiques
logique et durable avec les enjeux
environnementaux et donc de notre époque
pour vous est-ce que c'est possible des
Jeux Olympiques écologiques est-ce que
ce sera une réussite alors ce sera une
réussite en tout cas on y met des gros
moyens si je prends un exemple celui de
l'aménagement de la colline Delancourt
qui accueillera les épreuves de VTT en
ayant coulé zéro g de béton c'est quand
même un endroit extraordinaire pour cela
contrairement à d'autres équipements il
y aura aucun béton de couler sur la
cogne d'Élancourt il y a quand même plus
de 3 millions d'euros de ce qu'on
appelle les compensations écologiques
voilà un bel exemple j'insiste également
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas la
colonie Delancourt et qui nous écoutent
cette colline d'Élancourt en fait est à
initialement un tas de gravats qui est
lié à la construction de la ville
nouvelle les anciens les différents
déblairs et remblais qui ont été
extraits ont été entreposés à cet
endroit là il y a maintenant plus de 40
ans au fil du temps la nature n'a pas
repris ses droits mais pris ses droits
elle s'est installée alors une nature
pionnière avec beaucoup de boulot etc et
malheureusement aussi des espèces
invasives pour autant bien que ce soit
donc quelque chose qui a poussé seul sur
un tas de gravat et bien on va la
compenser écologiquement avec ces 3
millions d'euros on va en fait à l'issue
des jeux avoir une année entière de
travaux sur le site on va y revenir
voilà mais pour vous dire que on va bien
au-delà de bénéfique écologiquement
puisque la compensation à l'issue le
rendu sera en fait meilleur
écologiquement que ce qu'il était en
amont avec la suppression des espèces
invasives et la présence de par exemple
de nidification d'une partie des oiseaux
qui avait quitté la colline parce que la
renouée du Japon qui est une plante très
très on va dire qui porte atteinte à la
reproduction des oiseaux aura
intégralement disparu ça c'est un
premier exemple et un deuxième exemple
ce sont tous les efforts que l'on fait
sur le traitement en amont en aval des
déchets et la limitation des impacts
dans la partie transport je pense entre
autres à l'accueil des vélos alors vous
me direz comme on a des épreuves de
cyclisme il serait dommage de pas
pouvoir venir en vélo mais néanmoins on
y viendra en vélo avec des systèmes de
vélo qui seront mis en place pour
accueillir un maximum de la population
par ce biais de ce transport alors
justement accueillir un maximum de la
population qui dit Jeux Olympiques dit
beaucoup beaucoup de spectateurs on
attend près de 10 millions de visiteurs
en France pour les Jeux Olympiques
l'équivalent d'un pays comme le Portugal
la population d'un pays comme le
Portugal il y a déjà 12 millions de
Franciliens il y aura 15% de trains
supplémentaires prévus pour donc les
jeux alors quand on voit comment
fonctionne les transports actuellement
et cette année en Île-de-France on peut
se poser des questions est-ce qu'il y a
de quoi être inquiet selon vous alors
d'abord il faut être inquiet en amont
pour trouver des solutions si on n'est
pas inquiet on laisse faire je pense que
l'inquiétude elle est elle est existé
elle est en voie de se régler d'abord il
y a eu de très gros efforts de fait par
la région et qui vont continuer d'être
fait à travers son extension qui est
Île-de-France mobilité qui gère
l'ensemble des transports dont les
transports pour les Jeux Olympiques le
but c'est d'amener ceux qui ne
visiteront comme notre pop d'art avec
deux aspects ceux qui ne visiteront sur
les sites et la population qui elle sera
là de faire en sorte qu'elle continue à
travailler à se déplacer sans aucun
problème c'est un vrai sujet qui est
prêt à bras le corps par Île-de-France
mobilité et sous contrôle de l'État moi
je participe à de nombreuses réunions en
préfecture des Yvelines dont pas la
moitié mais un bon tiers des liée au
transport et quand on parle des
transports il y a le train il y a le bus
il y a comment on va d'une gare un site
je parlais tout à l'heure de la colline
d'Élancourt elle est certes en plein
coeur de 50 ans de vie mais l'éloigner
des gares il faut donc ramener la
population et les visiteurs des gars
jusqu'à la colonne des cours mais quand
on fait cela il faut faire des bus mais
il faut des quêtes temporaires mais il
faut des systèmes de signalisation mais
il faut du barrage mais il faut des
sanitaires pour pouvoir accueillir les
gens quand ils font la queue pour
prendre des bus il faut calculer les
temps de transfert pour que les gens
attendent un minimum leur bus en y
allant et un minimum de bus en revenant
tout ce travail est pris en compte et
nous aurons la chance à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'avoir le
seul Test Event de tous les jeux
olympiques où on va tester tout le
système quand je dis tout le système
c'est aussi bien le fonctionnement de du
contrôle des billets à l'intérieur du
site que le ramassage des ordures que
évidemment les transports et donc on va
tester le 24 septembre à Élancourt et à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines justement
toute l'après-midi transport pour la
colline des lancers
je tiens à dire également que pour 50
ans pas d'inquiétude les autres sites on
les pratiques déjà en transport on a
accueilli deux fois Championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste au vélo de
route nationale il y a eu aucun problème
de transport et on a accueilli la Ryder
Cup au golf national et on accueille
chaque année avec Sopor la période covid
quand même je le rappelle l'Open de
France de golf on accueille les
championnats du monde de golf amateurs
et tout ça c'est très très bien déroulé
la Ryder Cup si vous retrouvez des
images regardez en matière de transport
c'était juste extraordinaire une voix de
périphérique privatisée pour les Jeux
Olympiques où vous trouvez ça normal
alors pour les Jeux Olympiques je le
comprends on a vu d'ailleurs on en avait
pas privatisé mais on avait les mêmes
complexités lors de la Coop où on avait
dû avoir des couloirs temporaires de
privatisation pour faire passer les
différents convois officiels entre
l'autoroute A1 la porte de la Chapelle
et les différents accès ça je le trouve
tout à fait normal et je l'entends je
rappelle également que nous serons sur
une période de vacances scolaires et que
la majorité des Franciliens en tout cas
ceux qui le peuvent évidemment
financièrement seront en congés ce qui a
tendance à fluidifier évidemment le
trafic de manière très importante on le
sait après la question le corollaire de
tout cela c'est est-ce que je serai
favorable est-ce que ce couloir perdu ou
de la des Jeux Olympiques parce que j'ai
parlé d'héritage tout à l'heure il y a
des héritages très possibles dans les JO
hein le village des attelles qui
permettra de loger énormément de monde
la colline des longs cours qui sera
ouverte au public etc à titre personnel
En tant que Laurent mazouri en tant que
citoyen qui me rend fréquemment à Paris
pour raison professionnelle moi je ne
suis pas favorable par contre à ce que
l'on passe le périphérique de 4 voies à
trois voix voire de voir en laissant en
place à l'issue ce que Loire tel qu'il
est on voit dans les portions à deux
voies du périphérique car il en existe
autant de la porte de Gentilly au niveau
de l'accès d'autoroute A6 c'est pour il
dit que cela pose quand on passe le
périphérique de 4 de voies ou quand il
ne fonctionne que sur deux voies petit
sujet politique au sens noble du terme
en tout cas je peux avoir pas favorable
parce que ça perdure autre polémique sur
l'organisation de ces Jeux Olympiques
les réquisitions des logements étudiants
une partie des logements du CROUS seront
donc à disposition du personnel
olympique notamment les forces de
l'ordre il y en avoir besoin pour pour
donc par exemple la cérémonie
d'ouverture ou 45000 forces de l'ordre
sont attendus l'annonce a été envoyé au
locataire étudiant concerné donc ils
devront quitter leur logement les
syndicats étudiants s'y opposent
beaucoup ce scandalisent d'une telle
décision est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal alors je suis pas au fait du
sujet précis en question parce que nous
n'avons pas cette problématique ont été
sur 50 ans en Yvelines sur 50 ans
Yvelines nous avons tous des
infrastructures pour accueillir à la
fois les athlètes les services de
sécurité mais également celles et ceux
qui viendront nous visiter c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
j'étais chez un de vos confrères la
semaine dernière France Inter pour ne
pas les nommer et je leur passe mes
amitiés pour parler du problème d'Airbnb
et typiquement le problème d'Airbnb à
Paris derrière voir avec le projet me
dire
puisque nous sommes pas dans une
situation de logement sous tension donc
au contraire c'est une chance pour la
population et ça pose pas de problème
pour les habitants et ceux qui cherchent
à se loger après sur le fond et la forme
le fond du sujet que vous évoquez je le
comprends c'est qu'à un moment donné
effectivement si on manque de logement
il faut bien en récupérer la forme qui
veut si j'ai bien compris qu'à son
nombre de locataires du Crous a été
informé par voie d'un simple courrier du
fait qu'il quitter leur logement je
trouve que si c'est la seule forme qui a
été utilisée elle n'est pas très à la
fois efficace respectueuse et très
humaine donc je sais très bien et pour
connaître les instances qui s'en
occupent que les choses si c'est le cas
seront corrigés et je suis persuadé que
des solutions sont trouvées pour chacun
des résidents je rappelle à nouveau
quand même que nous sommes néanmoins sur
une période de vacances pour le coup
scolaire que nous sommes alors il y a
toujours des gens qui préparent
effectivement les sessions du mois de
septembre et du mois d'octobre pour un
syndrome d'étudiants mais pour avoir lu
des statistiques dans une réunion où
j'étais présente du taux d'occupation
sur les CROUS qu'il faut le savoir de
l'été sont de 32%, 32% des logements de
l'été sont occupés sur les CROUS et
c'est logique les personnes également
etc je suis si on est un petit peu
intelligent je suis certain que les
autorités trouveront une suggestion et
un mode de fonctionnement qui satisfait
tout le monde après voilà la forme elle
est évidemment un peu choquante je
trouve alors on a parlé des places on a
parlé des Fan Zone autre possibilité
aussi pour assister aux Jeux Olympiques
devenir bénévole 200 000 candidatures
ont été reçus donc les organisateurs
avaient besoin de 45000 personnes il y
en aura j'imagine besoin possible pour
les épreuves dans les Yvelines à
Saint-Quentin cela montre aussi selon
vous que ces 200000 candidatures que les
Français attendent et sont impatients
d'assister à ces Jeux Olympiques ah oui
alors c'est absolument vrai et là pour
le coup on peut en parler vraiment
connaissance de cause que 50 ans les
vignes avaient négocié avec Paris 2024
la capacité d'avoir au moins 1000
bénévoles de son sol qui soit
sélectionné venant de son sol sans ses
propres épreuves et donc nous avions
fait nous en amont un appel à
candidature pour tous ces bénévoles pour
tous ces volontaires que nous avions
proposé à Paris 2024 que nous avons
testé enfin les invités dans beaucoup de
choses pour voir leur capacités il y a
eu un engouement de dingue il y a
énormément d'habitants de Saint-Quentin
du jeune au plus vieux qui ont voulu
s'inscrire dedans pour faire tout
c'est-à-dire parce que quand on a eu la
vision de ce que moi j'appelle ça plutôt
les volontaires des jeux que les
bénévoles même s'ils sont bénévoles il y
a pas que celui qui va être au pied de
la piste en train d'attendre que le
existe des Vals la colline d'Élancourt
il y a ceux qui vont être je le disais
tout à l'heure ça peut paraître ingrat
mais à la gare et il y a ceux qui vont
être sur le tracé il y a ceux qui vont
aider à la collecte des déchets etc pour
autant tous ceux que j'ai rencontrés
étaient volontaires pour tout parce que
il y a un contact avec une population
étrangère qui va venir nous visiter il y
a le fait d'être fier de porter haut les
valeurs à la fois de son pays et de son
territoire de montrer qu'on sait
accueillir et vraiment c'est incroyable
sur 50 ans on le voit d'ailleurs chaque
année quand on a les différents
manifestations de golf qui appellent
également beaucoup beaucoup de
volontaires pour orienter les
populations demandez aux gens de faire
silence lorsque les joueurs jouent les
accueillir grosso modo pour un poste il
y a trois candidats ça demeure et
j'insiste vous l'avez raison c'est
bénévole donc on voit bien que c'est
purement par engagement altruiste et moi
je suis très très fier d'être
incontinois et d'être français pour ça
parce que en contrairement à ce que l'on
pense bien souvent avec la caricature du
français qui accueille mal vous savez
allez je vais faire exprès de provoquer
mes amis de Paris encore une fois mais
vous avez place de Trocadéro vous vous
demandez un café et dans le temps des
années 70 c'était et qu'est-ce qu'il
veut le monsieur et puis on lui donnait
le café on lui disait attention dans 10
minutes faut être parti parce qu'il faut
dégager la terrasse parce que je revends
c'est fini aujourd'hui on est une vraie
terre d'accueil du tourisme le touriste
et le bienvenu en France et le bienvenu
dans les Yvelines et à 50 ans et dans
cette dernière partie d'émission va
repasser justement en revue les
différentes épreuves à 50 ans
[Musique]
donc en dépit de tous cette question
d'organisation qui demande d'imaginer un
grand suivi un grand travail pour
préparer les Jeux qui donc vont arriver
dans dans 400 plus de 400 jours
maintenant
j'imagine donc quel a été votre réaction
lorsque vous avez appris que 50 ans en
Yvelines allez accueillir ces Jeux
Olympiques vous êtes donc vous suivez
ces questions sur le territoire vous
êtes élus à l'agglomération depuis 2008
la réaction évidemment j'ai été très
très très très content en même temps ça
a pas été
instinctif tout de suite parce qu'on a
eu également des combats en premier lieu
on a su que la France était retenue et
Paris était retenu pour les Jeux
Olympiques de 2024 mais ensuite on ne
savait pas exactement où aurait lieu les
épreuves donc il y a tout un tas de
petits combats offs ensuite il faut que
les territoires quand évidemment on
n'est pas dans Paris face valoir leur
qualité pour séduire le comité
d'organisation pour dire je reprends
l'exemple du VTT parce que c'est ce pour
lequel c'était plus compliqué parce
qu'on va dire que le vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je le
rappelle était
construit pour la candidature de Paris
2012 et et on n'a pas gagné 2012 donc on
savait bien que si en 2024 on faisait
des épreuves de cycliste par Roubaix il
y aurait quand même eu un sujet il est
pas construire d'ici là un autre vélo
national ça coûte dans l'ordre dans les
130 millions d'euros tout payé donc on
n'allait pas effectivement reconstruire
un vélo drone donc il va pas danger on
savait que ce serait chez nous le BMX on
savait que ce serait chez nous le golf
national il a été construit comme un
stadium de golf pour accueillir des
épreuves internationales de golf et il
accueille et il a accueille la Ryder Cup
donc et il y a pas de sujet la colline
d'Élancourt pour le VTT ça a été un vrai
combat parce que tout le monde
évidemment veut accueillir les JO pour
tous les éléments qu'on dont on parlait
tout à l'heure en termes ne serait-ce
que d'aménagement d'image et
d'attractivité d'un territoire là on
sait on s'est battu avec nos armes et
nos arguments je pense que 50 ans
c'était moins difficile que pour
d'autres territoires même ceux situés
loin à la montagne et il était plus
logique que ce soit à côté de Paris
encore que vous aurez remarqué que les
épreuves de voile sont à Marseille alors
on aurait pu s'attendre qu'elle soit
parce que c'était plus près et puis on
va parfois dans les DOM-TOM voir plus
loin pour des épreuves également qui ont
lieu sur l'eau je pense au surf par
exemple donc oui il y a eu un vrai
combat avec nos amis Montagnards pour
que le VTT ait lieu sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc à la fois
j'étais très content et ensuite on est
parti au combat avec les différents
maires adjoints vice-président et le
président de 50 ans Yvelines Jean-Michel
fourgouse pour séduire avec l'aide ici
je tiens à dire de la région de France
et de Valéry Pécresse le comité
d'organisation pour que Paris 2024 dise
et bien les épreuves de VTT ont lieu à
50 ans du vide voilà donc pour ça joie
et combat donc Vélodrome national pour
les épreuves de de vélo donc sur piste
oui golf avec le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puis le BMX le
stade juste à côté du Vélodrome ça c'est
les infrastructures qui étaient déjà
plus ou moins en place on va avoir tout
à l'heure si s'il y a eu des changements
mais d'abord je vais revenir sur la
colline d'Élancourt c'était le lieu donc
qui
n'était pas prêt au départ il y a eu des
travaux de son nécessaire donc pour pour
ces Jeux Olympiques un lieu qui était
déjà particulier puisque c'est tout de
même le lieu le plus haut de
l'Île-de-France 231 mètres on peut voir
depuis le sommet la Tour Eiffel la
défense ou encore la tour Montparnasse
ce lieu a été donc retenu pour organiser
ses épreuves de VTT donc il a fallu
construire cette piste
comment avancent les travaux aujourd'hui
mais ils avancent très bien je dirais
que à la date où nous sommes et à
l'heure on nous parlons ils sont
quasiment terminés vous pourrez même
dire qu'ils sont terminés les clés vont
être remises temporairement à Paris 2024
par la solideo la seule idéo c'est
l'organisme d'état qui est en charge de
la construction des infrastructures
olympiques donc il va aussi bien faire
le village des athlètes qui que
l'aménagement de la colline d'Élancourt
donc les clés vont être mis à Paris 2024
la piste est prête elle est faite les
différentes aires d'accueil sont prêts
et sont faits puisque sur la colline de
Lancôme ce sont des installations
précaires qui seront mises en place le
temps des jeux et qui partent le
lendemain des jeux pour rendre ensuite
la colline à au grand public peut-être
j'aurais l'occasion d'y revenir tout à
l'heure et à partir du mois de juin la
Paris 2024 va prendre livraison de
l'ouvrage et va commencer donc toute une
série de tests vérifiez que la solideo a
fait le travail comme c'était demandé
corriger éventuellement des petites
erreurs d'appréciation pour avoir sur le
tracé même si le tracé qui a été fait
par nicloos en amont et sur cette
parfait les problématiques d'altimétrie
peuvent proposer mais vraiment on est
dans le détail parce que le VTT c'est
loin d'être une épreuve simple c'est une
épreuve à risque et dangereuse il faut
avoir une piste compliquée et en même
temps suffisamment qualitatif au parait
à tout accident grave donc il y a un
vrai travail qui est fait et puis on
aura le 24 septembre le Test Event qui
aura lieu sur place ou là on testera
toutes les installations et donc
l'avenir de ce lieu de cette colline il
y aura une autre phase après les les
jeux une autre vie pour pour ce lieu oui
alors tout de suite après les Jeux
Olympiques ce n'est pas fini les travaux
reprennent force et vigueur jusqu'au
mois de septembre octobre 2025 pour
d'une part réaliser les compensations
écologiques donc je parlais tout à
l'heure mais également finir la
construction des autres pistes puisque
ce lieu est appelé à avoir des pistes de
VTT de tous niveaux depuis la piste
bleue en bas de colline jusqu'à la piste
noire qui sera l'ancienne piste des JO
hein et puis avec tous les niveaux de
piste un peu comme au ski mais également
la mise en place des différents chemins
piétonniers du mobil-urbain écologique
qui sera installée du platelage bois par
exemple au sommet de la colline de façon
à ce que les gens puissent admirer la
Tour Eiffel dont vous parlez tout à
l'heure la défense mais également les
verte quand on se trouve ne plus vers
l'ouest et pour rendre à la population
et l'ouvrir à tous à partir de la
rentrée septembre 2025 pour que ce soit
un lieu de partage mixte je tiens si
c'est sur ce point exemplaire puisqu'on
pourra à la fois y pratiquer du VTT et à
la fois s'y prendre en famille ce qui
est loin d'être le cas parce qu'en
général quand on a du VTT pour ceux qui
suivent un petit peu d'actualité on sait
que c'est parfois difficile de faire
coexister le VTT avec les promeneurs là
pour le coup la colline est pensée pour
permettre ces deux activités et les
pensées y compris pour accueillir dans
quelques mois ou dans quelques années
d'autres championnats du monde ou
championnat de France de VTT puisque les
infrastructures invisibles restent et
très rapidement on peut à nouveau
installer tout ce qu'il faut pour
pouvoir accueillir de nouvelles épreuves
tout en étant ouvert au grand public le
reste du temps et puis pour finir
j'ajoute donc les épreuves de cyclisme
sur route passeront aussi dans les
Yvelines depuis des années la
construction du vélo de route nationale
vous l'avez dit en pour à la base
c'était pour 2011 c'est ça début de la
construction il y a une grande histoire
entre le cyclisme
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui sera
encore qui accueillera encore la
dernière étape du Tour de France
les JO sont-ils l'aboutissement de ce
lien entre le cyclisme et les 50 ans en
Yvelines ah l'aboutissement
l'aboutissement déjà c'était l'accueil
du siège de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme rue Laurent Fillon dans le
vélodrome ça c'était un aboutissement
l'accueil également cette année puisque
les constructions la consommation court
de tout le centre de perfectionnement du
cyclisme non c'est pas un aboutissement
ce n'est qu'une étape nous accueillerons
j'en suis certain dans les années à
venir beaucoup d'autres manifestations
rapport avec le vélo d'abord on a
affaire vive le Vélodrome et faire vivre
le vélo Drôme c'est continuer à y
accueillir de grandes de grandes
manifestations internationales on a la
traque championne League par exemple qui
revient tous les ans maintenant au mois
de novembre un samedi soir qui est une
vraie fête du vélo un truc incroyable où
il faut vraiment venir en famille et
puis on ne souhaite jamais mettre une
fin à Saint-Quentin Saint-Quentin est un
territoire dynamique en développement il
représente 12 communes le but c'est de
le faire vivre et donc bien entendu
avoir les Jeux Olympiques je pense que
nous ne les reverrons pas de notre
vivant même vous qui êtes beaucoup plus
jeune que moi puisqu'on les a tous les
100 ans en moyenne mais néanmoins ça ne
marquera pas une fin bien au contraire
pour nous c'est un début merci beaucoup
Laure maçonnerie d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle donc que vous êtes
vice-président de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines délégué au
sport et aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de lobe de politique sur
Radio sensation et sur TV 78 très bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]